okay so for our next talk I'm very
excited to have Leah Boone who is the
founder of Alice kaja and we're very
excited to have her speak here we
actually personally invited her and as
you all know it's always a difficult
subject to increase diversity at
technical conferences so that's why I'm
a big thank you to Leia for coming today
and telling us something about happiness
and diversity at a technical companies
and at conferences thank you very much
hey nice to meet you um so I'm very
happy to be here and I'm my name is Leah
Valentin already introduced me and I'm a
code for a team development I have a
background and finance I have studied
economics and then I change to focus on
people and now i'm supporting companies
to create happier work environments
where everyone feels valued and everyone
has the chance to work productively and
work on something where they can excel
and are happy just to be in the right
spot so today I want to talk about what
it is that makes people happy and what
you yourself can do to influence that
and how this is linked to diversity and
you can ask questions any time how happy
do you feel today on a scale from one to
ten who's above eight that is not so
many like who's above five haha okay we
definitely need to work on that I hope
by the end of the talk we are like more
on a level like a buffeted okay um so
happiness as I already could tell like I
think every one of you knows what
happiness is and in general in life what
it feels like to be happy what it feels
like to have this state of energy and
just wanting to go out there and do
everything and feel light and just
enthusiastic about things and then there
is just very few of us who know what it
actually feels like to be happy at work
there is research done by various
institutes various very smart people and
for example the Gallup Institute I don't
know if you know a research institute
they found out that the percentage of
people that are actually engaged and
happy at work is just at thirteen
percent which is not so much and from
looking at how happy you hard right now
maybe there's some correlation to this
so and I think it might also be linked
to that we don't actually know like what
it is that we can do to influence this
and what it is that we need to be happy
and what we can do about it to be
happier so I'm glad there's researchers
that aren't taking care of this and I
can share some of the thoughts about
that and first I want to mention
something I think it's amazing that we
have actually the opportunity to be
looking into happiness because when we
look back at the past 150 years back
then people were working in factories
six days a week 15 to 18 hours a day so
I think we are already quite happy with
where we are now and I think it's not
due to like selflessness that we
actually made this development because
of course there has been research and
people found out why we should focus on
happiness and the findings about that I
then being happy at work increases sales
by thirty-seven percent it increases
people's productivity by thirty one
percent and it increases the accuracy of
tasks by nineteen percent so I think
that is pretty amazing and I don't know
if you know the Institute the great
place to work it's an institute that do
a yearly competition with companies all
over the world and they evaluate the
company cultures and how happy everyone
is in the company they do surveys and in
the end there's a winner and between the
years 1990
2009 the 100 best places to work have
outnumbered the revenue of the S&P 500
companies it's a stock market index and
by four times so being happy makes you
excel and have more revenue so it's
amazing I think and and what effects
does it have on you personally it is
that you are less likely to change jobs
you're more likely to be able to develop
your career and develop in your role
that you have and it boosts creativity
it boosts innovation and it enlarges the
thinking patterns that you are moving in
and it also has even effects on your
health it strengthens your immune system
and you have even a longer life and yeah
also happier people have larger social
rewards which means they have more
friends they have stronger social
support and they have more activity more
energy more flow and also it encourages
you to work towards positive goals so
being happy is a goal in itself I would
say does anyone disagree ok and ok and
the good news about this is that there
is a scientist a professor of psychology
professor from the University of
California Riverside her name is Sonja
Lyubomirsky and she found out that fifty
percent of your level of happiness is
due to your genes ten percent is due to
your circumstances that you are in and
forty percent forty percent is up to you
that you can influence your level of
happiness so if you're not happy now we
can totally change that um yeah so what
are the pillars of happiness there's a
professor which is called Howard Gardner
he has he's the co-author of
book of the good work they have done
research over I think decades and
interviewed thousands of people and they
found out that there are three things
that actually make you happy one of them
is excellent one of them is engagement
and one of them is ethics or purpose and
meaning that you find in your life and
now what we're going to look into next
thing is what the drivers of these
things are so excellence describes a
state where you feel competent where you
feel effective where you can feel that
you can excel on what you're doing you
feel that you are able to reach your
full potential you feel that you're in
charge of shaping your own future and
you feel that you have the freedom of
choice engagement is much more wider
topic and engagement is a state where it
is a state of dedication you feel
dedicated to something you feel
enthusiastic about something you feel
vigor and you feel absorption I don't
know if any of you know about flow I
cannot like say the name the author
because it's very complicated nice
thanks I just always read it and I was
not able to pronounce it Thanks okay so
um yeah this M state is achieved when
there are several things that add up
which is for example which i already
mentioned that you feel competent and
that you feel oh wait so there's two
components of feeling and gate there's
one thing which is called like you're
engaged with your company with your
organization and the other is that you
feel engage with your manager and it I
mean it's already a very interesting
when you look at it because people are
more likely to be engaged with their
organization than to be with their
manager or
direct supervisor if you look at the
numbers you don't actually leave the
company if you quit a job but you leave
your manager it's sixty percent and
above that people leave actually their
manager and not the company so and also
when you look at the numbers it's just
like thirty one percent that are
actually engaged with our manager so
it's very low number and the
organizational engagement is related to
confidence and organizational leadership
to trust that you have into the
organization to the level of fairness
that you feel that you have from the
organization to the level of respect and
to the values that the company has then
looking at the engagement with a manager
it's more or less the same thing but on
a personal level it's always directly
linked to your supervisor and it's how
valued you feel by your manager it's
about being treated fairly it is about
receiving regular feedback and direction
and it is about having a strong work
relationship that is based on mutual
respect so it's very much on the human
level i would say that makes people
engaged and ethics the third thing i
mentioned or purpose is about how much
do you feel that it makes sense what
you're doing it has meaning what you're
doing it has a positive effect on others
and do you have a shared goal that you
work on so now the big question is how
is this related to diversity and that
was when I was thinking when I was
preparing this no F and it's actually
that um I think that gender is just one
aspect that characterizes diversity but
there's much more to diversity than just
gender and also research has shown
and then for example the Gallup
Institute has done research and they
found out that female managers are
actually more engaged than male managers
female managers are engaged by forty-one
percent and male managers just by 35 I
don't know why and and it is even more
interesting to look at the employees
that are engaged with whether they have
a female or male manager what they found
is having a female manager on average
makes you six percentage points more
likely to be engaged and female
employees are more engaged when they
have no no female employees are engaged
when they have a female manager with
average of thirty five percent and the
least likely be it is that you're
engaged is if you're a male employee
with a male manager the number is just
add twenty-five percent I don't know how
many of you have a male manager so maybe
this is also why none of your happy when
I asked you in the beginning I don't
know um yeah so there's a book author
whose name is Susan finger she wrote the
book on the sexual paradox men women and
the real gender gap and it focuses on
how the biological sex differences play
out in the workplaces and what she found
is that female employees or in women in
general focus more on the things that I
have mentioned before what makes us
happy at work they focus more on being
happy at work on flexibility on having
respectful work for relationships on
intrinsic motivation and on having a
positive impact I'm sure there's
research that shows other things as you
all know research is always a bit you
can stretch it here and there but this
is what she found and for me diversity
is the hole bigger topic it is actually
about
staying open it is about staying open
for other people's opinions it's about
staying open and not so the reason for
it it's when you for example let's say
you meet someone and he or she says this
and that and like that fast you know no
I've always done it this way this way
and that's the right thing to do but
diversity also for me includes that you
stay open and that you try to listen to
someone and that you actually try to
hear what that person says that you are
not judging others by whatever they say
what they do how they act or what
question they ask stay open and try to
focus on what it is that people actually
need and where people actually want to
go and this is about finding the
connecting dots try to find the common
denominator that you have with the
person that you talk to and I'm sure
there is some because there's things
that everyone values in life it's as I
already mentioned the things it's being
respected it's having a trustful
relationship it's feeling valued and
yeah this is the things that you need to
focus on that you find that you have in
common with a different person and that
also gives you an approach to widen your
horizons so what is it that you can do
personally to be happier at work I think
all of us have been in a situation or
are maybe some of us are in a situation
right now where you're not happy at work
and to me personally there's always two
approaches the one approaches you can
wait for others to act and do something
that will make you happy eventually in
the end and I think the much like
healthier and better approach to do is
to be proactive about it tell people
what you need to be happy tell people
what you need to feel respected tell
people what they can do to show
you that they value you and communicate
like stay and dialogue with each other
and then also give back when was the
last time that you told someone thank
you at work I think this is something we
can do a lot more awesome and it shows
to other people that you respect them
and that you value them and you can talk
about expectations then I just said tell
them what you need ask them what they
need ask them if you should or can give
feedback to someone ask for feedback and
then also just find the right
environment for yourself I don't know if
any of you know this analogy if you ask
if fish to climb a tree you'll never get
there so find your environment find the
ocean that you need to be in to excel
and to be happy with your environment to
be happy with what you're doing and if
you're a manager you can do several
things and you can focus on the strength
of your employees focus not on pointing
out weaknesses that they have and what
they did wrong or and didn't do such a
good job at but just focus on strengths
what was it that they did especially
good today um know what your team is
working on and there was an experiment
once that they checked I don't know
there was some students and each of them
had a little task to do and there was
two groups the one was it was just
ignored what they did and the other was
the work was shredded right in front of
their eyes and they were like asked to
keep on going so these two groups were
like not motivated at all and they quit
after doing to us three things and the
other group they always got an online
looks nice and they just kept on going
and doing it and so know what your team
is working on if you ignore them it's
just as bad as shredding their work and
then of course have regular meetings
with your team members because otherwise
they will not know that you know what
they're working on
and help your team set performance goals
and also have like check on whether they
reach it or not and be consequent about
consequences and performance reviews and
this is what inspires me and what I
think is really important so it's really
just all about being happy and if you
focus on being happy at your workplace
and in life and you remember you have
these forty percent that you can
influence and the ten percent of the
circumstances makes you fifty percent
rule go ahead do it be happy and this
also leads to a more diverse team
environment stay open-minded and be
proactive about it do you have any more
questions how happy are you now okay
hahaha who's above eight hahahaha okay I
think it's just two more hands but it's
okay okay thanks
comments thank you very great talk we're
dealing with sports and with
high-performance teams and I think want
thank you left out this was from from
may I checked chicks in the Hungarian of
command area now live in Chicago but
what about a mission have you measured
to have a mission if you looked not to
diversity a gender and so on but you
have maybe monks or I don't know the
polo team but they had a polo mission to
fly to the moon and bring them back in
this decade so if you have you a strong
mission of course the Cold War and so on
but can you comment on this because if
you have a high performance team where
the female sporting or Olympic a male
team mm-hmm you have a mission and you
have a good motivation there is
something also intrinsic not also
external and one thing i miss was word
integrity integrity if you have
integrity in each person yeah because if
my boss is not good i can change the
next bus we have rotation but sometimes
i leave the company because the whole
company has a culture I cannot live with
I went to next culture a company same
culture it is an intrinsic problem so
maybe you can comment on this so to have
a mission mm-hmm integrity and something
will flow yes flow means in Germany safe
ever done and far done this means i
don't know look looked encourage and
demand not just support and give them
but also it was felan to get back maybe
you can comment on this so the first
thing you just mentioned was the mission
and yes true for me it also belongs to
having a shared goal and i don't know
like your question was now in particular
how it influences the motivation of
people
it does influence and if you don't know
what you're working on as a team I mean
having goals in general is something
that is I don't say it's natural that
you know how to set goals for example
you could say I don't know I want to
it's the always the same thing I want to
increase revenue or I want to be a
better company but then if you don't
know what exactly it is then there's not
much sense in pursuing it and for having
a shared mission it is also as having a
shared goal it's if you set a team like
if you as a manager for example set a
team like you just say you increase
revenue now by fifty percent this is not
something that people are going to work
on because it doesn't belong to them
it's not something that they put sought
and it doesn't it's not something that
they like want to contribute contribute
to because it doesn't belong to them
it's something like someone else told
them to do but is yeah as you already
mentioned it's not intrinsic you have to
be able to pursue your own career and be
able to be in charge and have the
freedom of choice and that is also that
it is that you have to have the ability
to contribute something and the other
was integrity and by that you mean that
you do what you believe in or for me it
is that you act to the the things that
you believe in that is for example if I
believe the company is [ __ ] for example
and I don't want to be part of it I do I
am proactive about it and I pursue my
next career step I keep on going and I'm
looking out for something that I'm
really into in that I really enjoy for
that it's important to be able to
reflect on yourself and know as I just
mentioned the fish in the water to know
your environment that the right
environment that you need to have this
flow flow is something it's um the
person we had yeah um he did research on
that wrote several books about it I read
one of them and
it's flow as a state of mind where you
are like you don't think about what
you're doing anymore and you're just in
the zone and they found it from they
looked at sports and they found it when
for example people that are climbing a
mountain are out in the it's like a
dangerous situation you can kill
yourself and you don't think anymore you
just completely lose yourself in the
moment you stop looking at the what of
course you're in the mountains and you
lose it and this is a state of mind that
he says is yeah the the base that we
needed work to be motivated that we need
to reach and so I actually have a quick
comment on that yeah so I really like
state of flow and I think that like a
lot of people in the audience who
program are very much aware of like this
flow and let generating flow is sort of
when you just lose time and suddenly you
know it's like the the Sun rises and
you've been programming all night
because it was so exciting yeah this is
like a state of flow and it's very
common sort of amongst programmers and I
was wondering whether you where do you
have any figures on whether like open
space offices are beneficial to flow or
whether they interrupt flow and whether
like open space offices are sort of make
people happier or whether they make
people less happy because I've heard two
sides of the story the one side is the
open space office is really important
because it brings people to bed together
and it enables collaboration and the
other story is the open space office is
actually really detrimental to my flow
is because it's always loud everyone is
talking around me and I can't like I
can't find my state to flow because
there's like always so much going on
around me and like I have all these
context switches because people come up
to me and ask me so do you have any
maybe figures or maybe some research you
know about on on open space oh yeah also
I have and I'm just thinking of if I had
both sides of stories but lately I just
read something that when people are
asked how they could be more productive
or where they would rather work it's not
in open space but I personally also
think that it's good to
and hence communication within the team
but also for this there are several
approaches to do it if it could be like
flexible desks or that you rotate within
the team where that's just one person
who like from your team goes to see
other teams so that you are aware of
what's going on in other teams and you
can enhance internal communication yeah
yeah I mean personally I don't like open
space offices that much and I prefer
like small offices with two or three
people and sort of having an open door
policy if the door is open you can come
in and interrupt me I'm free for context
switches and if the door is closed you
know I'm in a state of flow and I'm busy
coding and also I've just read something
that is awesome like interesting and
someone asked people where it's like the
best place where they can work and I
think most people just answer it at home
and at home it's that people are not
interrupted you don't have to check your
email so you don't feel obliged to
respond to anyone who's around you and I
think it's important that we can that we
are able to create something within the
team that actually gives you the
opportunity to feel not to feel at home
but to have the same setting for example
have no meeting Monday or no meetings on
Thursday day have you can like rebuild
this home office kind of thing at the
office itself to don't check your emails
so often don't be on the chat online all
the time it's yeah figure it out and
don't let other people pressure you into
being available different from this
subject I actually like the the part
when actually about asking for feedback
so you know sometimes when you ask first
feedback like you got that things in
your heart how about if I heard
something negative and of course nobody
wanna have something negative so how do
you think you can actually phrase the
question or request them for feedback
and just making sure you will receive
something constructive
instead of something destructive so how
can you freeze damn I think a good
approach would be I was just thinking of
an example that would relate to you but
I don't know if I can't for example if
you are doing something for a certain
reason okay for example you um I don't
know when to get up and for something or
whatever it is and you ask someone for
feedback and if you just ask how do you
think I did this and that they probably
just can say I would have done it
differently I think you could have done
this better this better this better this
better and I didn't like it but if you
say um I did this and that to get to a
state that this new feature was working
and I really put especially focused on
having a clear coat because I don't want
to review it so many more times whatever
when you explain what it was actually
that you're aiming for and then you can
ask how do you think I could have gotten
there faster or easier it's be precise
about what did you want and then ask a
question not ask what do you think how I
did ask for a specific advice of how
could I have done it faster how could I
have done it easier could i have sat
down before and thought about it to have
an easier or something or how could i
have used the resources from the team
better to get there faster what could I
have done to get your input on that like
ask a precise question on how you can
improve instead of just asking give me
feedback or how did I do because it's
not about judging others and when you
ask for judgment there goes it's just
you and they're probably not going to be
nice so just ask for a specific thing
that they could give you advice on and
how you can improve so I think we have
time for one more comment
maybe I can comment on this because
we're dealing with sports and this means
high-performance teams there's a slogans
means errors our best friends because we
learn from them if you look for children
playing means they fall down and make
your learning or robot machine learning
yeah so a mistake is not a faulty idea
that's all you have to have this culture
and I think if you have the flow you can
easily explain it especially for
scientists data scientists if you have
XY that code not in this Tamia the one
is the ability 29 por su mo sang another
thing this task is a task you have to
solve and it middle you have the
corridor of flow so if you are high a
high potential and you have a low task
you're boring so you're not in flow yeah
if it is too high you're overstressed
and there's also something like stress
and its distress and oil stress and I
think it's also very dangerous if you're
very motivated you know and this always
stress the oil place is going to
distress you lose the control where is
this so therefore is good a feedback
from external or we have guidance
guidance so the time I go for training I
go out or I have a meeting but a meeting
not not for not work but to make
something other to get your mind free
another thing we can learn from this
from kids yeah and from sports and this
is a very interesting topic I thing oh
thank you for great talk
you
you